[MUSIC]
There is a national dilemma on this,
and a real debate of whether
in particular detest sexual assault
kits from acquaintance rapes.
And we did a cost benefit
analysis of this, found for
every $1 you spend testing
a sexual assault kit you save
$81 on average,
to avert future sexual assaults.
There's always been a moral argument
to test this large backlog of sexual
assault kits and now we buttress that
argument with a strong economic argument.
[MUSIC]
Unfortunately what has
happened often in the past,
is that the hospital sends
the kit to the police department.
And there are currently around
400,000 sexual assault kits
just sitting in warehouses in police
departments throughout the country.
So think about that 400,000
sexual assault victims
go through this incredibly unpleasant
exam after a traumatic sexual assault.
They do it so that they hope they
will find the offender by doing this.
And then they kit just is sitting around,
and they never investigate it at all.
[MUSIC]
When a victim of a sexual assault
goes to the police department,
the police encourage them to go to the
hospital to get a medical forensic exam.
And there the nurses try to get some
foreign DNA from the victim, and they take
these swabs and put them in a box, and
that's called the sexual assault kit.
And then the hospital sends it
back to the police department.
And ideally what happens at
that point is that the police
department sends it to a lab,
the lab tries to get DNA from these swabs.
If they get DNA, they run it against
the national database of felons.
And they try to get a hit, and if they
get a hit against that database, so
the DNA in the swab is the same as the DNA
in the database, then ideally this hit
would become a conviction,
you'd actually put someone in jail.
[MUSIC]
The cost of testing a sexual
assault kit is around $1,600.
And the average amount that we save
by testing it is around $130,000,
which is 81 times bigger than the 1,600.
So, again,
every $1 we spend we're saving about $81.
That's an incredibly conservative number,
the actual number instead of 81
is probably a couple thousand.
Because the chances of conviction now
are much higher than they were in
the data that we estimated from New York,
because the statute of limitations
are much larger now in most states.
[MUSIC]
There's many other benefits from testing
these kits that we didn't quantify.
So one big one is we didn't quantify
the costs associated with nonsexual crime.
Which are actually larger than the costs
associated with future sexual assaults
because these people on average commit
more nonsexual crimes than sexual crimes.
It also brings closure to the victims.
It also, an interesting study people
find that it helps deter future crimes.
If you actually get the kit and
you put this person into the database,
that once this person finds
out there in the database,
they will commit fewer future crimes.
There are some people out there that
are just serial sexual offenders,
and not just sexual offenders but
many other violent nonsexual felons.
And we have the technology,
we have the wherewithal,
we know how to get them off the street,
we just haven't done it.
And there's an easy way to get some
of these people off the street, and
we should do it.
[MUSIC]